I am so excited about my podcast called
pretty intense thank you for having me
in your podcast thank you I'm a fan only
podcast ever where you're going to get
that transition you're gonna win a Super
Bowl video you already won the game son
[Music]
the stronger the emotion you feel with
some problem in your life the more you
give it your attention where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're giving your power away
your life force do not go to the selling
business go into the reorder business so
my biggest piece of advice to the
American public is to watch something
that you don't agree with at least 100 a
week 99.99% of all parties went through
as though nothing was there god I love
science
I'm not even done yet I had a dream to
be a baseball player and I wanted to be
a CEO of a major company oh my god and
what happened there not an inspiration
to dream
we're being bed and I'll say you know
you really did treat me like a wife
today figured out once that men would
live five years longer without the
masculine my marriage is going good
that's my wife right there do you not
treat me like your wife you can treat me
like your girlfriend and we'll be fine
she's flirting with me and if you break
a bone or you break your back you get an
IV of this antibody and you rejuvenate
like a salamander how do you know when
the line is crossed there are two forms
of sexual harassment in the workplace
ones pretty easy to discern it's quid
pro quo I got the rebound I'm coming
down elbows out and my sense that you're
gonna try to steal it I have an elbow
you in the face make it look like a like
I feel like I'm like a joke in my head
if there's something I want when it
happens not if it's gonna happen it
essentially means you know sleep with me
for the promotion or you're fired
it's kind of blows my mind Thanks let me
let me complete the mind-blowing
please dimension of this nothing scared
me more than always staying a welcome
that's where I should end then because
I'm pretty sure you need to go Danica
Patrick and I'm pretty intense
[Music]